the damning new allegations against
ellen degeneres
these new accusations come less than a
month before she is set to kick off her
new season
and this weekend ellen was leaning on
her good friend
kevin hart i'm a friend as a friend if i
have a friend in trouble
ever i'm gonna do my best to try to be
there for that
the meet-up just 11 days after the
comedian came to ellen's defense
amidst her talk show scandal this
morning we learned that ellen is back in
production remotely
the staff is ellen's priority right now
but there's a new twist
people like ashton kutcher and katy
perry
have no idea what it's like to be an
ellen staffer
a woman claiming to be a former camera
assistant spoke anonymously to an
australian radio station
alleging that the culture at ellen was
so toxic
it was like the devil wears prada that's
all
most people are told when ellen enters a
room you and your entire crew need to
leave
i think honestly ellen has no idea who
most of the staff even
are you can see on david letterman's
netflix promo she walks around the
offices and
you know really has no idea who we are i
don't know who that is
i'm ellen i'm your boss nice to meet you
the show is under an internal
investigation by its parent company
meanwhile remember the golden rule
did big brothers julie chen moonves take
a dig at ellen's trademark
be kind sign-off be kind to one another
be kind to one another be kind to one
another
be good to one another do unto others as
you would have them
do unto you julie told ew her ad-lib
remarks had nothing to do with ellen
but were a way for her to show support
for black lives matter rights
and mask wearing